Jack stat signaling pathway is an
important cell signaling pathway it
starts with ligand binding with the
extracellular receptors which lead to
its dimerization
later on it activates the genus kinase
or Jack which are recept which are
actually non-recepted tyrosine kinase it
phosphorylates The receptors in its
cytoplasmic domain which further
recruits stat and leads to its
phosphorylation phosphorylated stack can
stat can dimerize and it can translocate
into the nucleus stat stands for Signal
transmission and transcription So
eventually it would lead to
transcription of many genes
and it is super important for interferon
signaling pathway where the virus
infected cell secretes interferons and
that leads to Jack stat pathway in the
nearby cell and that leads to the
production of antiviral molecules